This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by sat for luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina.
Hey, there it is. Gene.
There it goes. There it is.
There it was.
Just keep on moving as you
like to say how he's like,
just keep on moving. Keep on trucking.
That's the saying I invented.
You did not invent, keep on tracking.
Didn't invent that. I didn't. Nope.
I feel like I'm a hippie and that's Kinda
my thing is like whatever happens and
die there will goes.
We have a lot to get into.
We have a very exciting podcast today.
We do a,
we have not one but two guests,
which was the very first time we've ever
done that. Unprecedented, unprecedented.
Maybe the last time we'll ever
do it. It's harder. No, I know.
Not a reflection on them.
It's just like we have one
seat so there can only be one,
but now we have to do,
but then I know another duo that has asked
to come in that we should accommodate
too. Oh yeah. I mean, I just
tell you off Mike, I think, oh,
what if I tell you and you're
like, Oh god, tell me, tell
me. No, I can't. Oh, come on.
I'll tell you off mic. But
they're coming. All right, let's,
let's do a proper show open. Let's
get this thing going. Right party. Ah,
those guys suck. Yeah, that's what I'm
saying. I look to that. Here we go.
I'll tell you. I'll tell you, but
come on up. Here we go. Here we go.
Hi, I'm Lucas were and I
want to have kids someday.
I'm prepared to offer $1,000 to the
woman with similar needs that wants to go
out with me to dinner
and Herschel in Spokane.
So if this is you,
please post a video response,
um,
detailing why you want to go out with me.
Yeah.
What does he want? He wants
to have children. Yeah,
but he's offering $1,000 just to go
out to dinner. Oh my gosh, I see that.
Do you think he's that bad?
No, I think this is a bad idea.
I think it's a bad video. Well,
first things first, bad angle.
You don't want to make a video where
you can see the smoke detector on the
ceiling. That's always the sign of a
lunatic is when the smoke detectors in the
background is, don't even show it. I mean,
and also it's unflattering
to have the camera below you.
You want it to be above you or
at least even with you. Sure.
He's standing over it like anybody
want to have dinner with me? He's nice.
Um,
he must have really hit some huge
barriers to have to make this video though
$1,000 to have dinner with him and
Spokane guys. We, we have fans in Spokane.
Please. Somebody go out with this guy.
I mean, you don't need a grand, do you?
Hi.
I'm looking for,
and I want to have kids someday done
prepared to offer $1,000 to the woman with
similar needs that wants to go out
with me to dinner. And it sure.
In Spokane Churchill,
if this is you,
please post a video response.
He Alien.
Why you want to go out with me?
Is it a nice restaurant? I'm hoping.
That's what I'm saying. Let's look it up.
Get a church hills and Spokane.
Let's see. That's kind of a
desperate a steakhouse. Oh, well.
He's got good taste in food and it's
a nice steak house. It says. Yeah,
I'm a lot of the thousand dollars.
I mean,
I think there's a lot of women out
there that would love to have a family.
They don't need $1,000. He's
not very nice, but he's not
that unfortunate looking.
Oh yeah, they got a wireless. I got to
pull up to these entrees or lobster tails.
This is a nice place. The stakes
are beef is strictly USDA prime.
Top sirloin Ribeye. Cowboy rib eye. Yeah,
a flat house filet mignons.
There's a fancy, this is a,
this is a high ticket place to, it's
$50 for a steak. This is a nice joint.
You can have cougar gold Mac and
cheese on the side of the cougar claws.
Sounds good.
It asparagus with balsamic
syrup or hollandaise sauce.
This is very nice. Yeah.
Oh, cheerful photos. Oh,
so braised beef tips. I
love it. Alaskan king crabs.
Now you know how many holes he's going
to have just shown up for this free meal.
[inaudible] stone crab claws here.
Listen to me, that's only in season.
You know how many slots are going to
show up just to eat for this the thing.
And of course be interested in children
and I know they're going to abuse him,
but he's, he's setting himself up.
I'll tell you why man. Cause you're,
you're leading with the,
the money to have do that bad idea.
Well you should be doing is
just like, Hey, I'm single. Um,
I live in Spokane, I want to have
a family one day. But you know,
one day what I really want to do is
just meet someone. Does anybody like,
would anybody like to get together,
have dinner and talk about some of your,
maybe some of your interests fortnight
or whatever you're playing these days.
What? I'm work night, four
nights video game. Oh, um,
you know, I think he should
just lead with what, who is,
what is genuine interests are.
Would anyone like to have dinner?
You can just say that. You don't have
to mention that. It's Churchill's.
Anyone like to have dinner.
I bet you're going to get a response
from someone in Spokane that this single
and wants to have dinner with you.
I think you're right because
actually I need to have,
his approach is like a rich guy,
douche bag of pressure, and it's wrong.
When you think about it. It's like
the guy that owns girls gone wild.
What's his name?
That's how I imagined that guy approaches
bitches. Like, Hey, I want this. Uh,
I'll give you $1,000 to just
show up. Take it. It's like,
it's such a douchey thing. Totally
Douchey to lead with money. Yeah,
and to be like, you know, if you're,
you're conflicting what your desire is,
how you're getting it,
because you're saying what I really want
does meet someone and have a family.
Yeah.
I'll pay you just to consider me.
You would get off on the wrong here. He
says more. Let's see what else he said.
This guy is really sad.
I'm 37 years old and the quencher here,
my date has to be under the age
of 26 I know it's a weird request,
but I'm offering $1,000 so I think you
can see past the age of them to go out
with somebody that is fully
prepared to become a father.
Oh wait a minute.
This is way weirder than I thought it
was five seconds ago under 26 that's a
weird age cut off.
So they have to be at least 10 years.
11 years younger than him. Why?
I mean I get you like young,
but I mean why is it that specific?
Hell don't know.
So she's a smoke show
and she's 28 you're like,
you just didn't make the cut smoke shell,
you know?
What did you learn that word from?
I don't know, about six years ago.
I've never heard that. Really? I've said
it a hundred times in front of you. Smoke.
Show me like she's smoking
hot. Yeah, I've never,
I maybe I've never listened to you talk,
but you're also kind of removed
from culture and slang. Terrible.
I don't know. I don't know any
of this stuff. I know Nana,
but smoke shows pretty
common. Um, so I shit,
brick house, brick shit house.
Fuck. I can never get that one.
You always get it wrong. I know
why? Because my, it's a Hungarian.
It's probably because my mother said it
wrong and I put it wrong so that this
guys knows Joe.
Joe,
how you say martyr?
She said she mispronounced everything,
but this is all fucked up now.
You got to do what's going on when he six.
He's a Douche bag. I was,
yeah, you're right. I actually,
I was giving him more credit
because he looks sweet.
The problem is like the look, he has
his kind of like a doughy software guy.
This guy could find a nice girl. That's
not hard, but he's at now. He's like,
I think you can oversee. I'm giving
you a grand, but here's the thing,
what are his, what is he expecting that
at dinner at Churchill's he's like,
so I want a family that she'd
be like me too. And he's like,
do you want to just try to start one? You
do on a fight. How families are started.
You don't just eat dinner.
And I go,
did you imagine that courtship
story to their children?
And I put it out on the Internet asking
$1,000 for any hoe under 26 I paid your
prostitute prone mother to have
dinner with me. Yeah, your slut mom.
A free steak is what
she got out of the deal.
She had children with me and that's it.
That's all it took for your materialistic
slut, mom. Okay, he's going to get worse.
Here we go.
Why worse
a little about me.
I want to go and get my AA degree.
I am writing a book about Calamari
through research suggests that men between
the ages of 35 and 55
give kids for her DNA,
uh, associate's degree. So yeah,
but see now I think what he's actually
trying to suggest is that he is in the
cause as part of his,
uh,
his research or something that he's
in the age group to give better DNA,
but for creating a family and a child,
the younger woman would
be the better. Yes. Oh,
I mean biologically speaking, I should
have had children like 16 now I know.
Perfect. But to put it in your
ad is, is still the straight,
so he's saying that 33 year olds to
50 year old men have power outages.
That DNA. Yeah. Jess. I
don't think it's just,
he's talking about what's in
the jet deep in the gym. Yeah.
Well you're just is very powerful.
Powerful time.
[inaudible] we've made two children
off your ges. That's very true.
Giving is duty or accelerated age.
You're 48 years old. I'm not 48
the doctors were like,
is he 58 how long to see your
spirit and was very fertile though.
We always test your sperm before we had
Ellis. Yeah. Cause like, yeah, I'm older.
And then what was your, he's like
your sperm counts through the roof.
You're like 20 million. How many did you
have in alone? There was a lot. Yeah,
it was good. He was like, yeah, you
keep nothing bro. He said it like that.
I was like,
that is not medically appropriate.
Remember when you just in the
Filipino nurse helped you?
That was so fun. Yeah.
What did you say to her?
Well I went in the room and that they
were going to make sure I have good judges
and she's like, you know, she's
at, her eyes are down. She's like,
here's a TV here and here's a remote.
Yeah.
And you can find some porn on there
cause they have it set up to watch porn.
I was like, oh cool. And they go,
so do you stay? She was like, no,
I can't stay with you. I was like,
I'm kidding. Stay has the best.
Yeah. But she got, she was like, Oh
yeah, this is before we had Ellis and uh,
we decided to hide the plumbing checked
out because yeah, I'm an old man.
I was all mom. Oh bitch was 38. Yeah.
They read you the riot act to do with it.
And you know what's weird about
the judges when they test your ges,
they go shoot it into this cup.
Yeah.
And make sure your penis doesn't touch
the cup. That's like impossible. I know.
And you're like, what do you mean? And
they're like, don't have it touch inside,
outside the rim.
Just have the,
just go right in there and then then
just cover up. And how big is the cup?
Is that it's a shortcut? Is
it like a Dixie Cup? No, no,
no. It's, it's a plastic cup,
but it's, you know, it's
not that deep and it's not,
I mean it has a big enough opening
but just not deep. You know,
they should have bigger openings for
your Dick [inaudible] and they have a
specific,
I remember they were like,
make sure you haven't come
within the last 24 hours,
but no more than three days.
Oh.
Cause that's also bad to have it
backed up for too long old Jay.
Interesting as Algiers. Yeah. So
you gotta have like semi fresh Jess,
how's or the days those
were the days they no more.
Here we go on.
Herschel's is a very nice place.
We offer the $65 porterhouse steak.
Oh my God.
We'd go out to dinner and
enjoy each other's company.
Maybe have further dates and similar
restaurants in town because I have enough
money to do this.
All right. We get, we get it. This
dude, this guy's fucking tool. Yeah,
this guy's terrible. You need it so
much worse than I assume now. I hate it.
I thought he was like, I didn't realize
how calculated and just delusional he is.
Yeah. I thought he was just
kind of Goofy, like I love,
I just want to go on a date.
He's just, he's wrong. He's
going about it all wrong. Yeah.
He might be like Asperger's or
something or he doesn't understand it.
Sure hasn't blinked a lot
since this thing started.
He probably doesn't understand
human relationships. Yeah.
I'm guessing he's on the spectrum.
He's touched just a little bit touched.
Just touch.
Are you touched just a little
smattering of touching. Yeah.
He's touched somehow.
He's in disguise.
Fine.
I will talk to you soon.
What is so wonderful? He would take me
to dinner. You're not going to, man.
I'm going to Spokane and May, but
what if I, what if I just do a video?
I shave.
I put on a wig and I go,
I saw your video on the
24 I love Churchill's.
I love steaks and I want a family one day.
I like $1,000 and I want,
can you wire it to me before we go and
I liked houses and then I'll do a little
kind of shoulders.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It could be. You could
dial me up to look pretty enough. Never.
I think you'd be the ugliest woman I've
ever seen. Excuse me. You would be,
you'd like, you could never be
transgendered. You would never pass.
So it would take so much surgery. Cause
your, your shoulders are so broad.
Like you're such a macho looking man.
The laser alone,
the Lasik on your face to get rid
of that beard. Yeah. Oh my God.
You have so much testosterone
swimming in this body.
I really think it's rude that you
said, Oh man, you're a hideous woman.
God dammit. Do you think I could
pass for a boy? Yeah, I can.
I kind of have like eastern blackie
features and the older I get,
the more I look like my dad. Like I'm
aging into my dad, not my mom. No,
you don't look like your
dad. Oh, I look terrible.
I can pass for like a fake
kind of guy, right? No,
no. You look great. Like
a gay guy. Yeah. Yeah.
I should dye my hair.
Look like an ice skater guy.
All those ice skating guys.
You're like sad.
I asked the guy what those plump rumps
that you liked so much plump rump.
High cheekbones. Yeah.
Those guys are all straight.
I could, I could almost go on
a date with one of those guys.
They did something with the hair and
put on an APP. If they were like,
do you want to have dinner? I'd be
like, sure. Yeah. Cause their bodies,
the suits that they wear.
Yeah.
I kind of Foxy lady bodies and the
rumps the rumps got to die for.
It would be like, Ooh, it's
going on. Yeah. They kind
of do just lemon, a wallets.
Do you walk around with that's
really thick in the back.
They do look like just bigger women.
Slightly bigger than the women
they're skating with. Yup. Yeah.
I wonder if they're like the hottest
commodity in the gay world figure skaters.
I know. What is the hottest
combined? Who's the,
who's the top of the totem pole in the
gay world because there's so many like
different, yeah. Well it's just
your, what are you attracted to?
I think it's the same thing, you know,
because there's the super successful,
um,
there's that lane of the executive who
also spends three hours a day in the gym.
Like Andy Cohen. Like,
yeah, like Bravo TV guy.
He's super successful gay food chain
for, yeah. Yeah. For sure. He's up there.
But then there's what I'm saying,
like the super yolked once,
you know what I mean?
Like where you see it's like just
all muscles and you see them,
but they're like 50 and you would
be like, dude, you look amazing. 25.
Yeah, it's really nuts. There's that.
But then there's the, the bear lane.
No, no, I'm saying like the objective.
Okay. Cause in the straight world,
objectively speaking,
you know,
the handsome rich guys are the
top of the food thing. It's this,
it's the same thing.
The Jack and,
um,
there's degrees to jack though.
I think ultimately the Gay George
Clooney type who's top of the food chain,
he's also top of the food chain
in the straight world. Right.
It's just the like the symmetrically
good looking super successful guy.
Yeah. Yeah. I guess so. And
in my and the woman's world,
you have to be like 12 years
old. Like 20 right? No,
no older than 28 otherwise
forget it. Yeah, just hot,
super hot. It's a good thing is that as
a woman, you just really have to be hot.
You don't have to have a degree.
Like guys don't care if she's successful.
There's a brain out doing your
own thing all the time, knowing,
and then the talking, if she has a brain,
you don't want to hear her talking.
And that's true. That's true. So
basically it's a woman, you know,
you want to hear her talk,
you just want her to hear her say like,
you're totally right. You're
the best. I love you. You're
so impressive. Yeah. Yeah.
God. So much easier being a woman. Oh
my God. I don't want more qualities.
This is good the way it is. It's
good right now. Right? I mean look,
the expectations are so low for us,
it's like if you achieve even more than
what's expected of you, you're like,
people are blown away. So great
for me. You on the other hand,
why guys bar's way too
high for you even vented,
everything is achieve everywhere.
It's like too much pressure.
You have a lot going on there. Like you
don't have that much going on. Right?
Like what? But for me people are like
super impressed by what I got going.
I'm like sign with that big of a deal
compared to my husband with white guys,
I feel like they go, if you
go, this person did this,
this and this. Most people go,
that's pretty great.
You know what this other guy did?
That's always the next sentence.
Cause the other guy he did,
he did what you did and like 10 other
things and he invented penicillin and won
the Nobel prize. He's Ilan Musk. You
ever heard of that guy? That guys,
that's the thing is that the gold standard
for men is like Elon Musk, let's say.
It's totally different standards.
Obama, of course being president,
no matter whether you like
or dislike any precedent,
that's an unreal achievement. And the
female gold standard is like Gal Gadot.
You decided to be like hot, super
hot. She's talented, very talented.
So maybe not even her,
but the thing about being super hot,
cause you have nothing to do with it.
You deserve no credit
for being super horse.
No one's saying this is an equal
system. No, I'm just saying in general,
men or women, when you're beautiful
or stunning, gorgeous hair,
you deserve zero accolades.
You did nothing. You were
just born. Of course. Yes.
That's why being a woman is advantageous
in some regards. If you're attractive,
right? If you're a dog,
forget it. You've got to work.
You got live like a guy and it's even
worse because they don't respect you like
a guy I know. Fucked up man. In the way,
it's kind of good if you accept that
you're unattractive as a woman because you
actually start getting treated like
a human being. Yes. Men will be, uh,
you know, sorry I spilled that
mustard on you anyway. You know,
it's like they just treat you like a gag
me get you a beer and like they don't
treat you like a puppy. Treat you
like a person. Yeah, that's true.
I would say in my twenties I was treated
like totally differently. And then you,
you age and to being a person when you're
turning 40 as a woman and you're like,
oh, this feels so much better. Like I'm
being treated like are like, uh, not like,
uh,
Amit.
Her big fuck with a lot of women is
that when they're in their twenties and
they're being treated special
and they're attractive,
if they don't have foresight and the
ability to see that that will change.
Then when they age thirties
and forties and 50s,
they go through their own selfimposed
trauma. Yeah, true. True. Through trauma.
And they don't know how to adapt.
And this is when you see
certain women go crazy,
they go crazy with surgery,
they go crazy with philosophy.
They go their philosophy on life.
They're reading Heidegger. No,
they're not reading Heidegger.
They're saying that like they have
conspiracy theories about this and they
started to, yeah. But
the women who have, uh,
a real head on their shoulders go
like, oh, this is a time in life.
And then there's one other time
and I need to not just rely on
exterior. Yeah. Well I think that's great.
Good. Uh, counsel for men and women. Yes,
it's true. Listen, the, the outside
fades. Glory Fades. Beauty Fades.
No one looks amazing at 70.
We're all going to look like shit anyways.
You might as well develop a
nice personality, right? Yeah.
And interests and it'll be a good
person. Geez. Yeah. Well I like that.
We just broke down all of society.
That was really good.
Well,
the reason we were talking about it is
because we were watching an interesting
show about society. You, I have to give
you full credit for this. Thank you.
You have an ability that I have
never seen anyone else for.
Would you rather the best? Would you
rather you've ever heard on the show?
Kristina came up with,
I don't know how your mind works.
Your diabolical, evil, twisted,
truly psychopathic mind works.
Uh,
and also to find these fucking shows
that are horrific and fascinating and I
can't turn them off. You're
welcome. This one, you're welcome.
Is it age gap or love gap?
I think it's a lot of, yeah,
age gap on Netflix. Okay. Yes.
I do feel as though I'm
drawn to the truly depraved.
I like to find these shows that really
make you feel gross inside called age
gap. Love, age, gap love. Yes. So
this one is a, it's a British show
finished. We talked about recently
that we've finished love after lockup,
which I just didn't think it could
be topped. It's so fucking fantastic.
And that's a show where ultimately what
we walked away with is we have much
greater empathy for the fellas that had
been released into society than the sad
souls that insist on dating them and,
and basically manipulating them to be
how they expect them to be once they're
out of prison.
It's all about control. It's like I
want to hold this person hostage. Yeah.
They're in prison. They're not going to
cheat on me. They can't do anything wrong.
And then when they get out this immediate
push to marry because they want to
keep my log down even more.
It's so sick.
So with this show it's about
people who are dating or married.
I think they actually all married on
the show married who we just finished
episode one, so you can join
right along with us. Uh,
who are married and there is
a significant age gap, uh,
between the two people.
These are married people at the show
was filmed all in the UK and they're all
hideous.
They are horrifically unattractive.
I mean the ugliest human beings on earth.
Love these people have
age gaps in between them.
I think perhaps as
little as 18 or 20 years,
as much as 40 years in
between them. Uh, we have uh,
an 80 year old woman and a 40 year old man
cause I was like something's wrong
with this guy. And then he was like,
something is wrong
cause he was like,
I fell in love with her.
I lived at home until I was 30.
I enjoy playing the organ.
You're like,
this guy
tied to this guy and then he comes
in his goofy ass fucking sweater.
She's like, no, he'll pull up.
He's up on baseball robot.
Oh,
I have my own problems.
It's called pink Avnet. Em, my jumper.
It's so bad. Then there's
the set. Our favorite Ah,
is the 74 year old man who drum roll just
became a father for the seventh time,
right? Seventh time by seventh
child, he's five adult.
He has five adult children who the oldest
is 50 to get your life and then he's
on baby number seven.
He's 74 which I don't know as a
father and as an expectant father,
the idea that I'm going to be 74
new this you see us with rock star.
Mick Jagger has done this and
no,
John Stamos was on the cover of people
at least having my ultrasound 50s and
people are celebrating him.
Like I knew dad at 55 like why are
we celebrating this Douche bag?
You're an asshole. You're fucking
total selfish piece of shit.
You are setting your kid
up to not be around. Yeah.
Like chance at the May.
Of course you're like,
well what if I do live till I'm
a hundred okay, that's possible.
But you think like
you're guaranteeing that,
well not these English motherfuckers.
Cause the guy who's 74 he runs
a pub so his face is bright red.
He drinks every day.
He looks eight and a half months pregnant.
You got one of those.
It looks like there's six tablets.
You mean it's hard and round like
Kate from John and Kate looked,
she parable. He looks terrible. Yeah.
He's not living the life that's
conducive to living together.
Then there was the other guy,
I mean at least he's not having children
and he really looks like dog shit with,
they all look my fucking dog shit. Then
he's just great. He fucking, he's like,
Oh ah, I lost my breath there.
And she's like, sit down, sit down. So he
just loses his breath every few minutes,
just standing, just standing.
And, and of course he's gonna,
he's gonna die by the
episode too, for sure. Yeah.
But these people have in kids
at that age are such assholes.
Yeah. Cause I don't care. There's
no, there's one couple that,
there's two couples that anger me.
It's the one who the woman was 40
and she hooked up with a 16 year old.
Of course that is a illegal,
he's a child. It's wrong. Yeah,
so that's fucked up. It's abuse. It's a
really, it's not okay. And then there's a,
the couple that have children,
the 74 year old guy in the 30 [inaudible]
and that from a 16 year old,
by the way,
maybe when she was 40 I can
see if you're 16 is enticing,
but she turned in to a
full on hound and she is,
she is whoof whoof brigade.
It's not good.
Oh yeah. They're all bark. All dogs
though. What are you talking about?
Even the guys are dogs. They're
all fucking dogs. Yeah, it's bad.
But what's my favorite
is the elderly lady, she,
she had a husband for 50 years and on the
deathbed the husband said to go find a
toy boy is what they call them in England,
I guess not a boy toy. And she has,
she wears is Cleopatra eyeliner. Oh my
God. And she has white, white, white,
white hair and what?
Tom?
Oh yeah, she's got, um, triple H. Yeah.
Tits big fakers. They go fakers, which
is fine. She's actually, you know, she's,
she seems fun. Yeah. But
during the sh the episode,
it's got these crazy triple h tits.
She's like,
I think I want to go get bigger tits and
goes to the doctor and you get an exam.
And he was like, I really don't think
you should. You tits are enormous
cause he goes, the skin is sagging
already. So you're going to have these,
these cantaloupes that you can't even hold
up. I think their worst thing
has to be, cause I mean,
I'm at a certain age now
and I'm okay with it.
It's gotta be horrible to
resist and resent your aging.
I think that's going to be what I, one
thing I don't, I don't give her so much.
I don't care so much about the
physical appearance of me aging.
I'm worried about not being able
to do the things I want to do.
That that bothers me. Like rock
climbing and all the love rock climbing,
karate, all these things.
I do scuba diving.
It's just like jumping out of bed
quickly or going up the stairs without
worrying about my hip breaking.
Um,
you got a long time hopefully for
that to worry about just doing Pilati.
It's like I was listening to Jane Fonda
talk about it and she was like the
workout queen, you know, and she still
works out and she was asked like,
well how do you work out
now? And she goes, well,
very slowly and very carefully even though
she's still does like stuff like that
kind of bums me out when you're like,
I have done this thing now.
I've been doing weightlifting with a
trainer and now as opposed to just a few
years ago,
I do a ton of warming up before I lift.
I don't go like I used to just walk in
and be like, just pick it up and go.
I have tweaked and just kind of hurt
things so many times now that I make it a
20 minute process before I do anything
of significant weight, which is smart,
which is going to, I think it's gonna
get worse obviously as you get older,
you know, so you have to get
your body ready for that shit.
But I'm not so much worried about that.
I'm saying that like when you're like,
when she, that lady's like 75
or something, the tits one,
the big tests and she's,
she's essentially like,
I gotta be hot and you're like,
you're 76 years,
you're not in that category anymore.
Yeah. And she's, you know, always wearing
tight and revealing things in this thing.
Just be old.
Just be like a really
good looking older person.
That's fine to be dignified for your age
as far as where you can't buy that low,
you can't by being distinguished her.
Well, cause the thing is, I mean,
you and I've talked about this before,
especially like let's say women
in their forties in my age, uh,
you can get all of botox and all that
shit in your face. You don't look younger,
you just look shiny or, and weirder. Yeah.
You never really look younger because
of this crap that you do. Right.
You just look weird.
So you choose between looking shiny
are looking your age. Yeah. It's like,
okay. And you're not fooling anybody.
You really are fooling people.
There's not a lot that are,
you're definitely not pulling
anyone unless your doctor drew.
That guy looks fucking
amazing. God Damn. Yeah.
He's like jacked and his face
looks great too. I what? I bet.
I bet he has some secret Dr Formula.
He's not telling us how he's doing
doctor Shit. For sure Doctor Shit.
We're going to get him aside
one day. He'll be like, oh,
I didn't tell you guys have been doing
secret. Dr Shit. Yeah. I drink blood.
He's a vampire. It's children's
blood badge and law. Should we,
uh, take a quick pause since our guests
supposed to be here any moment. Yeah.
It's probably easier to do it now.
Yeah. All right. We'll be right back.
Hopefully when we press record again,
we'll be with guests. All right.
And just as I promised, uh,
before we took a quick break,
we're back and we're being joined by,
not one,
but because of their own
demands to guests. What? Yeah,
which is a first for this show. It's
always, it's in our podcast writer.
It's in the rider.
So you have to have us have both on hand.
We have like an a lengthy
writer. Uh, don't look us.
No eye contact throughout
the entire thing. Yes.
You guys are known to be jerks kind of
in the, you can look at my tits though.
You can look at him the whole
time. I, when I, when you
talk to me, I'm like, Hey,
I'm down here, down here. I'm
down here. They go by the Bros.
They say,
always say they always lead with like call
us bros or don't call us at all. Yeah.
Yeah.
What's up bro?
They go by the joke Bros Bros
or hear a funny bunch. Uh,
by the way, so I should say it. The
sly brothers, of course we are here.
They're the supplier brothers. Yeah.
They are comedians. They have specials.
They have, um, great pot. You have
more than one podcast to podcasts,
dumb people town, which you've done.
And you will tell people is really fun.
You're coming on
a and then a view from the cheap seats,
which is sports and comedy.
But we took a deeper dive into sports,
which is actually really fun.
But sports too, you guys are uh,
we're known even before obviously the
podcast you guys had ESPN show you gotta
show on ESPN called Yeah, cheap. Yeah.
Back in the mid two thousands there.
Michigan men. If I am. Yes,
you are correct. We just
won the big 10 tournament.
What a great dad and a feelings.
Good feelings.
It was like that is going to come
through a dude. It's going to work out.
Come through.
You're wearing like Michigan colors.
Do you think that's an accident? No. No
it's not. Yeah, I did it for you. Um,
it all free.
But before we get too far out of the way
and I know we'll get sidetracked with a
bunch of stuff.
Uh,
one of the main reasons you came on
besides the fact that we are thrilled to
have you and we love you is that you are
promoting a new movie that I think is
going to really click with our audience.
I will let you go ahead and tell us
the name of your new documentary.
Well first of all, it came out last
week. All right. It's called poop talk.
It's a documentary about poop.
Why is it something that everybody does
but people really don't talk about it.
You guys talk about
and your fans talk about it quite a bit
so that you will love this will love
this movie. So it is people talking about
it. We released it last couple weeks.
We're like, we should have
called the movie the Brown
Panther. That was a misprint
toilet water lady.
Turd lady term would have been great.
Thank you.
It's like the week after you shoot
your special and then you're on stage,
there's no pressure and you're like, why
didn't I ever say it this way? So good.
Now I understand what the bits really
about get it out would have been fun to
come on. Why so many? So many.
So it's called pep talk because I
mean truthfully as we were naming it,
we as Canadians wanted to give it
like a clever name. We're like,
we should call it fecal matters, you
know, something. Another good one. Right.
And then every or we said talking
shit or shit talk or whatever.
But the people who were kind of in
MDF would sue you. But yeah, I got it.
Well he'll say he's going
to sue US anyway. Yeah.
Cause we did one college last year.
He's going to sit this way and we're
huge in Australia. Uh, I love Edia.
So wait a minute. So tell me,
take me through the origin of,
I mean we're already fighting,
but like how does the idea,
like the idea come to let's make this,
it was not our idea.
Our friend who we went to camp with WHO's
actually a really smart filmmaker set
came to us with this idea
two years ago and said,
I want to do a movie about the history
of Poop and I want you guys to help me
produce it and get past. So here's the
thing, you know how with every car,
I'm sorry to cut you off,
every comic especially, uh,
you talk about there's certain
wheelhouse topics that you know, like,
like make them smile, light them
up. So if you say, you know,
you could talk about like, I'm
definitely a, if it's sex, dirty,
dirty dirt old school dirty jokes. Yeah.
That always makes me go, I go like, yeah,
somebody tell me and murder,
but a,
there is fantastic 100% through the
more than 12 years that I've known
Christina, if you, if somebody says,
and then someone took a shit over there,
she's like,
what if she starts laughing?
[inaudible] I actually have to pull back
from writing so many poop jokes in my
act. I've had other comics and be like,
Whoa, poop jokes once you had a baby.
Like it just like everything comes out
when the baby, Oh yeah, other people,
shit comes out of you. It's like all
sorts of stuff comes out. So wait.
So your family's secrets was said,
I want to do this. See? And we said,
I don't think we can do this
movie because I don't know that we can
handle this the way we just weren't sure
that we can handle it. And
so he said, don't say no.
Think about it over the weekend, the movie
you'd want to make. And we were like,
all right,
if we get funding people to be honest
about how they feel about it and try to
make an honest film, it'll still
be funny. And if we get at like,
why is this something that, obviously
you're comfortable talking about it.
We're comfortable talking about it as
Comedians, but why or why do everyone,
why do we pretend we don't
do it? I mean, that's just,
it's an insane that there's like we've
passed, when you think about sexual stuff,
you've passed so many tab. What used
to be taboo is like, that's like way,
way. Do you feel like we're swinging
back around the call to sac to him,
more Victorian era. Millennials? Yes.
Hannah called millennials or you know,
just the entire movement of like,
can I put my hand on your hand? Is this
going too far? And you know what I like,
this is a job interview so you can't,
I didn't experience this
in the past 10 years,
but this year I have never had
such strikingly different sets.
Blowback, indifferent. I'm saying
saying you can do a set yup.
In two different venues and feel like
you did them 30 years apart. Yes.
That I've never had before where I'm like,
cause you're like,
I know this material works everywhere
and I know exactly what the last points
are going to get on them.
30 minutes apart where I've
been in a venue in Los Angeles,
Donna said ain't shit to
a point where I'm like,
I don't even know if I know how to
do standup anymore and I'm scared by,
by the reaction that I got and
then drive to another place,
do the same set and have it like a stroke.
Right.
Yeah. Well, what's interesting,
I mean, I'm always a big,
I think that's a great thing,
like we should always be staring into
the abyss of your own career saying like,
how the fuck are we gonna do what's next?
Because I can't trust
people who just are always,
they're essentially just straight up.
I'm like, not that I can't trust them,
but I have nothing in common with
that person because you always have,
I feel like you are a better comic and
you're a better person when you say like,
I mean that's why actors who rise
up don't lose touch with reality.
But when you're a comedian and
you put yourself out there,
you stand on the stage to liberty.
I on this to show on Saturday night in
Detroit and it was a show for the next
generation Jewish Federation,
800 people at this big Butte of the film
or theater play the showroom downtown
in Detroit. Very cool. Nice
place, beautiful venue.
And I thought 25 to 40 year old Jewish
people were going to like light it up.
We'll just live in the pocket
of our material and they, it,
I'll fucking exactly you open
with that that goes with that.
But I was like, and again with material
that we've been doing this with tail,
we know it works. We know where
it's going to do what it is and uh,
it was definitely like we were sledding,
we were,
we were slugging it out with these
people and I literally at one point where
it'd be like, what are you
guys doing? You're here,
here and here's the, here's
the truth man. The worst I,
I'll say it from myself as somebody
that we live in a progressive city,
we all are pretty liberal minded people.
The ultra liberals are the worst comedy.
They're terrible. It was hard. So I
have no sense of humor. They don't know.
Like part of what we do is cross lines.
You want to cross. That's the fun part.
Set up. Yes. Go ahead and let the
audience laughs. You haven't crossed it.
You've just found that lovely edge. It's
right. We say where is the, we were,
we were hosting the final
draft towards okay. Finally
writing thing. And there
was, and there was,
it's still around and they would give
these lovely awards out and it was at the
paramount theater was about 500 people
there was really cool and we're like,
okay,
let's bring out the trophy align,
let's bring out the trophy so you can
see it in our beautiful woman who comes,
comes out. They're like, can we please
have the trophy girl out here? I'm like,
that. That's maybe a little too
offensive. Knowing the audience,
right scholar what you really is,
trophy wife.
So that was a joke. That was fine.
We knew that was going to be okay,
but then I said, listen,
you know, I'm sorry,
sorry for that joke and
we're sorry to her. I said,
I'm sorry for everything that Hollywood
has done and probably will do to you.
So I like that they are like that,
but I was like, you know what?
I don't give a shit.
The first thing worked and that's all
that I really care about. But it was,
it's just, again, that's what we do as
me. It's this fine line. Those people
start to get when they're at show start
having such an awareness of like they
want to be right rather than have fun.
Yeah.
I mean it goes both ways.
It's like,
I mean the crazy thing is we have material
in our show that is anti, you know,
anti Trump.
We tell how we feel about things.
You're being yourself in Rochester and
we kind of present the topic out there
and like half the people don't
want anywhere what we do.
I had to say no and we're like,
all right,
well you're jumping on board with us
because we'll actually make a point that
even if you support the guy,
you can't deny that we're right.
That we're wrong on this.
We're right.
But it's interesting that
we're what we're all saying.
It sounds like everybody's divided.
There's two kinds of comedy audiences now.
It's split much like people who
support Trump and don't like,
I think the country is just
divided, right? You did all that.
We just did a project that is also,
it's coming out on audible.
It's like an audio book and we were
jumping off the poop more jumping off the
pool. They're moguls. We do this. We have,
oh yeah, I'll go over like little tiny
little bumps at the bottom of a ski run.
That's what kind of mobile, so that's
the kind of models we are and so like we,
so anyway, it's about, you know,
you go, you guys go into a town,
we try and experience as much as we can
in that town and then write comedy about
it. So we set the challenge plane lands
on Thursday. If you're doing Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday night shows,
can we write 10 minutes of material
about the town that we're in?
That's your guy's like selfimposed yes,
we did this on this project.
And so like local material that
then speaks to a larger, broader,
it's an audio book.
It's each city is a chapter and they
follow us from the second we land
throughout the second
observation and the field,
like each chapter is about 35 minutes
long, 40 minutes long. And so, you know,
he's basically three documentaries in one.
What it's like to be comedians at
our level traveling around right now,
I grouped, you know you guys are
the guys are beyond our level.
You guys are in a different level then
what it's like to be in those cities
right now. What? What is, what is
Denver dealing with? Right? How has,
how has we'd change?
Never can gay people still live in San
Francisco who they can't because they've
been priced out by tech Bros. What's
Kansas City grappling with right now?
Like how,
like what's Houston like
after the hurricane we were
there for the hurricane and
then after the Astros one, like
what are they, what's their mindset?
So it was so it was all that and then it's
about what it's like to create a joke.
Like how do you observe something in the
moment? Like when we were up in Buffalo,
we did this like a long time ago.
I didn't know that Rick
James is buried in Buffalo.
Fucking buried above that should be
on their airport. Welcome to Buffalo.
Rick James is buried here,
bitch.
So we go out to his fibia statute.
We got the guy forcing a woman this
beating a woman with a crack pipe.
So we go to his grave and we're like,
and taking the audio at
the grave and it's insane.
We're walking out to this grave
and there are people at the site,
they're like Hawaiian Leis rest because
I guess nobody repped Hawaii better than
Rick James. Why? And they're like empty
beer bottles and stuff and we're like,
what was artfully placed here versus
what just blew in from the highway.
And that is probably a better, the
best metaphor for the guy's life. Yeah,
it's like his trash was also
going on to other people's,
because this is an audio book that's
coming out audio, so it's on auto,
it's called Sklarz and stripes.
And what I've gathered so far from you
guys being here with us, we'd gone,
you guys are lazy and you really
get your shit together.
And then you guys will love this.
As we pulled six minutes out of each of
the 10 cities and we made a comedy album.
So the album is going to cry as well.
And each track is like just Tulsa,
Kansas City. So it's just a different
way to do comedy. I'm so that,
the crazy thing about that is the first
weekend we did was San Diego American
comedy company. The weekend after Trump
got elected. So that was bat shit crazy.
And then the next 13 months it was
crazy going around to Kansas City,
St Louis, Madison, you know Houston,
these are not all blue state.
We're not all going. Yes,
you went to Portland yesterday
in San Francisco, but San
Diego is a little mixed.
Went to a lot of different Louisville
the week that he was elected. And what
did you do? You did like a a theater. No,
I did. I did the club. I did the club.
That's the club in lieu of laughing derby.
I don't even know if it's still doing
it right, but it was the week of and a,
that's a blue city in a red state class.
But for the shows is definitely mixed.
Yeah.
But what I learned that week,
and this is like the week of like he
got elected Tuesdays and Thursdays.
Those are weekend in San Diego for
my show, which I'm like, I don't,
I didn't have a lot of political stuff
and stuff, but like when I brought it up,
everybody was like,
can we just talk about something else?
And then we would, you know, I would
joke around about a couple of things,
but as soon as I just moved,
everybody was like,
oh think like you could tell
that they were just like,
it was a literal that week for sure.
Legal though was worried.
Like we got into the wall. We're like,
Shit Wall's coming ball. Do you want it?
Whether you fucking want it or not. We're
like, what do we do with it? We said,
you gotta have fun with it. Rock
climbing wall on our side, on our side
to help them over the wall. And
then we still have you, boy,
you've put a rock
climbing wall on our side.
You could book your kid's birthday party.
Where are your kids?
Had to breath down with
a wall if I can go on.
And then we sat on the other side of
the wall for 200 yards up to the law.
It should be the American Ninja
Warrior course. Yeah, Mexico.
Cause if you make it through that,
you just deserve to be an American citizen
on the stock. Had a drummer. Hilarious.
Great idea. That's how we get our
sentence. I guess the citizenship
not only remained calm
an American citizen,
you already own your own crossfit gym.
Small business owner.
And so then that's great. So, so we wrote
that that weekend that we were there,
we're like, okay, this is what's on our
mind and this is what's bothering us.
And as we were feeling very helpless
and frustrated and we're like,
this is going to come,
no matter what,
maybe some people will are going to
be psyched about it. Maybe they won't.
But if we can make the whole room laugh,
then we've done something in this moment.
Even if they're laughing at some
of that's not political. Okay.
And you have read that we, like you
said, you did the rest of your set,
the rest of your step,
they're laughing at,
you get what you're saying
to them essentially without
them even knowing it is,
hey, you guys have stuff
in common. Like let,
let's let the homerooms laughing
at his old sex jokes. Yeah. Yeah.
And the whole room that you made a
room full of people who probably,
if you weren't talking we'd be
yelling at each other. Right?
You made them come together and laugh
at this and that is what we truly,
that's like the beginning point.
Yeah.
I do believe that that is
the beginning point. Hey,
we have stuff that we can all laugh
about. Let's, let's start there.
And then obviously we disagree on other
things, but it was, that was fascinating.
So that's called scars and to drive.
That'll be out on April 5th on audible.
But it was a fascinating thing
and I think his standups,
you guys totally can appreciate.
The other thing is you go on
the road and I know it's hard.
It's hard because you guys
aren't together. Do you
travel together sometime? No.
So you go separate places. Yeah. You get
out there, it's very easy to get isolated.
Just stay in your hotel and
not lead really the whole
time. You just stay there.
Shit.
You just jerk off the whole,
he does. I order room
service, I eat, no, I eat.
I feel like it's got you start
to, what is it like, you know,
retract into a dark place. Yeah.
The week as long. Oh yeah. So like,
you know the, yeah, but you don't bring
someone to open for you though. I do.
So what happens? But even then, a
lot of times they're like, you know,
they'll text me, hey, what do
I do? And I'll be like, just
leave me alone. And then,
but then you know,
I'll bring the opener. Who will leave me
alone? I don't, he's gonna leave me alone.
Person with a heart condition. You
can't walk up hills. They're like,
I'm just not going to walk up that hood.
You're conditioning yourself
to the point where you're like,
I don't need to go that way.
But now it's been enough years of touring
where I'll recognize that it's not
healthy. So what I'll do is I'll,
I'll tell the person, like, we are
having lunch and like seeing a movie or
doing something tomorrow for the next
leg of my tour.
Tony Robbins is opening.
He's going to motivate me to get my ass
up because sometimes you go, you know,
you're, it's like day two or three
and you're just like, God damn it.
And just the act of leaving the room and
doing any, it could be the most Monday,
it could be coffee at the corner.
You're like, oh, this is better.
I'm not just sitting in the road.
So when we were getting out and then so
we would put it on us to like write this
stuff. We were like, and with
the crazy thing about this, this,
we did it in Rochester and we weren't
even doing it for the project.
So we were in Rochester this
past weekend and we're like, oh,
let's see how much material we can
write about Rochester. And the guy who,
you know, open for us was
really cool and we were like,
and we brought our buddy up from New
York who feature for us. So we're like,
all right, we're like a
Forman. Cause when we go,
well if I like a descending on a
town like you're a band. Yeah, yeah.
Me and were like, we're going to go
do this and we're going to do this.
We're going to go out afterwards and
we're going to do this. Because for us,
we're like, if we're away from
our kids and our families,
we're already getting shit
for being away from home.
I am not going to have a bad time.
Right?
Like I want to enjoy myself because the
amount of flack I'm getting from being
away,
I've never heard of that.
Or you don't get anything that she
does not give you any flack whatsoever.
Five months pregnant and he leaves. It's,
it's fine. It's fine. It's still fun.
You can handle, you can handle it. I
mean talk about something else. So that's
the good news is that your
son's on a handful either age,
rage is self sufficient.
Yammer likes to take,
never likes to take your lipstick
out and write on the walls
and it should be fun. Number
two, there it comes out.
The second child talking
about guys who have two kids.
I've got 10,
a 10 year old and 12 year old.
I just dropped my 12 year old off
yesterday and you want to talk about like
moments.
I just dropped her off.
He yesterday at the roller
skating rink for like, uh,
just her and her friends.
That was such a moment.
I literally was like about
to cry and then Michigan,
one of the big 10 tournament, I was
like, ah, there is a god. And I was like,
don't ever happens to her is fine.
Just don't get stabbed.
Do you like Your Life Christina?
Oh my God. We witnessed that once.
Witnessed a couple who
invited us over and it was a,
were older than us, very nice
house, like very successful.
And um, we were new,
you know, like a new cup
and we're just sitting there and
they're serving like this. Nice.
It's like a late lunch and they have it.
They invited a couple other neighbors
over and they have this big nice house.
And then she,
she uh,
started telling him, she was
like, Jesus. He was like,
look at your body cause like you're
really like really have let yourself go.
And I'm like taking a boat
to her husband in front of
and, and then I'm like, oh my God, he
let himself go. I just want to know dude,
I would pay. So had he had, first
of all he was at four pack abs too.
He was an all American in college at
a division while American douchebag.
But like, so he just looked
like a like a 55 year old.
Slightly added. Yeah. But like
not bad and look bad. Okay.
And then rate for 55 every morning.
We heard him doing his fucking
laughs at five in the morning.
So can we just say he goes great
for 55 average for 36 fine.
So she said you really let yourself go.
You guys go,
because I think he took like a big
serving. It's just because Jesus,
you're going to eat all of ad.
And he was like, she's like me.
You should have seen what it
looked like when we got married.
And then I like put a, I
put like a spoon. I'm like,
I guess I'll have small portions.
Right. She shamed you. Oh Man. Yeah.
And then we just kind of, you know, she
says that melts and goes, let me say it.
Let me ask you this. Do you like
your life? Do you like living here?
How do you like your life? And I was
like, you know, did you add one point?
I was really like, he's got
a point. Yeah. Oh, of course.
Because she did nothing for her.
Children were grown and like living at
home didn't like her life is the answer.
Well,
I mean to me,
and you guys were talking about
the Olympics on a previous episode.
I mean that is, and this is,
I love when anybody starts,
this is why I love your podcast because
it's like deep, deep relationship.
We were talking about why we love, I
guess is great. Okay. Here's what it is.
You can talk about it. You're both
funny. That's it. That's the end of the,
that's the end. That's the
beginning of the end of the day.
It's not a funny guy with his wife who's
also along for the ride or hilarious
dom husband. It's like you guys, boop,
you guys both attacking on a high level
and your relationship was so great.
I ran in and we're like,
can we ask them at some point today during
the podcast if they would open their
relationship up to just the two of us
can we'd show tomorrow with you guys and
let me just ask you both.
Do you like your life?
You guys have to commit to family dinner.
I fucking love.
I just love how you guys talk to each
other and even if this is the only time
you talked to each other like
this. No, I love it so much.
It's the healthiest aids like,
do you want to know why? Why?
Because we talk about pooping in
front of each other. That's it.
Did comes back to our movie, comes
back to poop talk, which I can,
I just lament that we have you guys
in the movie. It's very upsetting.
I'm going to get out in front
of this apology. You know,
here's the thing. I first,
we had dinner a few weeks ago with,
uh, Brian Volk wise. Yeah. Who
in charge of, and he goes, oh, you
know, he goes, I have this, uh, the,
we have this documentary
talking it up. Yes. He goes,
I have a documentary coming up. You're
going to love it. And I go, what is it?
And he goes, it's about a poop.
And I go, what's up poop document?
And he's like,
well,
it's like a bunch of comedians
though talking about when I'm like,
my heart's sinking. I
know. How would we not
invite,
you don't invite us literally.
But this is literally the
studio that poop built.
This is this work in a
poop building right now.
We only make the sequel number to seduce.
Guys are all over weight. When your
friend tells you you, you think about it.
And we said,
no,
I don't think we can do this cause I don't
know if we can do this the right way,
you know, truthfully. But then
we came back to him. He said,
think about how if we could get comedians,
I mean there was no budget and we had
like a day to do it. I guarantee you,
by the way, if we would have asked you,
you guys would have been gone out of town,
but I'm not trying to,
you're totally posture and then because
we had like a day to shoot or two days
to shoot,
but it was one,
it was one of those things where
we call the Improv and said,
can we film here during the day?
Yes.
They gave us a fair price and
helped us with, which was amazing.
We pulled a bunch of people on we,
Brad Williams is a comedian who I love
who's in the film and he's so funny.
He was not someone we thought to ask.
He just happened to be at the Improv
that day. He's like, what are you doing?
We're like, we're making a
movie about poop. He said,
I said, do you have a story?
Just for the hell of it, and he was
like, I have the story. And I was like,
do you want to hang? You know his
story, I don't know his story.
I'll do the setup for it. And then you
have to watch the movie. Did he tells,
by the way, I think the centerpiece
story of the movie and we didn't,
we didn't even ask him to be in the
movie and he just shows, luckily there,
so he goes into a public bathroom at a
restaurant, it take a shit and he's like,
it was a club maybe. I Dunno where
ever it was. He said the, he has like,
I guess I have to use the handicap stall
because that was a little person worth
coming into our community in his
way. He describes it. And so he's,
but he's got big ideas guys. And he's
very sensitive. He would never use it.
Oh No, no, no, no, no. He's
like, I go into the bathroom,
I go to take a shit. And I'm,
I guess I'm the one who's supposed
to use the handicap stall,
so I'm gonna use it and he gets in there
and the toilet is somehow higher than a
regular toilet.
So he's got to get up on and his,
as he describes like the parallel,
parallel and back,
we'll say, can we take a look at the
trailer just for a moment? Let's just see.
I mean, I don't know if it's
a, it's in it. You're going
to be, I'm going to be mad.
Let's see what,
don't yell at us.
I just hated pooping so much that I
figured poof is excess food or whatever.
Oscar loser obsessed,
but trying to keep the right
amount funny on the Oscars last,
but then I would still poop people clock
my restroom visits because somebody
will see me go into a
bathroom and be like,
oh that's the guy from modern family
and be waiting for me coming in and it's
like, man, I'm glad I
poop. They'd be like, Whoa,
he's bigger than I was.
Five minutes in.
There was this very powerful disgust
biology associated with it and then the
culture reinforces all that with
shame and embarrassment. Okay.
With you knowing that I'm doing it.
I'm just not okay with you hearing it and
I'm not okay with you smelling it idea.
I really think it's
called number two because
the second best thing you
can do with your body.
My mother used to call them bowel
movements. Oop, oop, oop, oop, oop, oop,
Ooh,
right.
I definitely think about where
the most people, I don't know,
maybe everybody thinks about the block
is the only thing that we can all agree
on that everyone does.
It might be slightly different,
but we all get it the way that we
can take in and eliminate impurities.
It's a biological marvel. I don't think
I've ever pooped in Royal Stadium.
I don't think I've ever
pooped in Dodgers stadium.
I know I've never pooped at staple center.
Great Line hoop all down my leg. Oh,
I love making my legs. Didn't dangle below
the door. Another dude, when he left,
he thought he was by himself in the
bathroom, so we just turns off the light.
I was freaking out.
Terrified by me.
I may have cleaned up nick Swardson's
poop a hundred percent true by the way.
It's a super funny movie.
That's great.
I'm done with my poop talk.
So his daughter named the movie cause
she called it a little Virgo. Uh, yes,
we are bummed that we didn't ask
you guys to do it. Super Sad.
They deserve all the shit that you guys
can throw. Well, I tell you this, we were,
um, when we first heard about it and
we processed that after Brian, I was,
we were kind of hurt and then
angry and then, you know,
all the stages of grief. I go through
all those stages when I took a shit,
of course, literally something that
could leave, then we realize that death,
the two of us are actually, um, working.
We've been working on a
documentary and it's not, yeah,
something,
we're 45 years old,
I guess who we didn't call it.
I am addicted. I'm addicted to Becky. Uh,
one of 'em
w w are uncertain days.
Does the novelty, um,
get old. There are moments
where you're like, Eh,
and we fought for years to
not be seen as a gimmick.
We wanted people to be like,
that's a great comedy team.
Oh, I mean though, not on,
honestly, you guys are are a great
comedy till you guys are great comedians.
It's a, it's no doubt at all about
it, but I'm saying like, you know,
if something like six eight everyone's
going to be at least as the weather up
there bro. And every day,
all the time, look, we're,
we are grown men with families and we
aren't seen as the Sklar brothers or twins
in our family.
Like just,
the guy was gone for two days and didn't
get anything done around the house and
one's mad at me.
I'm the guy who forgot to
pack the undergarments for
my daughter, for Les Mis,
you know, I'm like, that's who I
am. I am identified as that person.
So when we're walking,
especially like if we're doing,
you know how many at a city,
some other city or somewhere that we'll
just walk down the street and they're
like, you got, that's so cute. We're
like, no idea. Be Six year old.
You guys
quiet guys. That's so funny. You
guys finish each other's sentences.
That's so great. We're like,
Hey, let's stop focusing on us.
Finishing each other's sentences. And
let's focus on Oj finishing one sentence.
How about that? Yeah, how about that?
Because the guy hasn't no are are a
really is annoying and, but you know, we,
we're, we're nice people. We try to not
get in. People get the fascination though.
I understand the fascination too because
on some level where like we are trying
to judo that fascination
into something deeper,
which is most people see it and they're
like, did you guys ever switch on girls?
That's a, that's a deep seeded
thing where like he says,
you mean pull off a rape?
Is that what you're asking?
Am I really excited to hear the
story about that? Number one,
we didn't go to Michigan State.
No.
Number two like that is the most bizarre
thing for, yeah, that's what I mean.
And you're just like, because we use
the good one and who's the bad one?
We're like, yeah, that's right. You
know, people aren't nuanced at all.
I mean there's no, you know,
there's no, we're like, we're both,
we're all that thing in,
in every,
so there is a little bit
of that fascination and
truthfully we understand how
much we bring it on ourselves by working
together, being on stage together.
It's like we know that like we're
stepping into the store, those girls,
we don't dress alike and we are
addicted to it. We are like,
there are moments where we've like shown
up at shows and like similar without
even checking with each other and like
why I got to go onstage in a Parka.
I mean that's what I'm wearing today.
One of us has to die go home shirtless
thing where you pick up the phone on.
The other ones are,
I don't know if we can do that nowadays,
but back when we had regular phones
and then the other one's on the,
on the line right there now,
although the one time in our lives,
this is pretty recent,
which is insane that something weird
happened that we couldn't explain it and
now we just want to pretend
it didn't happen. Uh, we,
so we were going out of town to do it,
get totally explain it by the way.
We're going out of town to
do a Gig, clearly explain
it. And we always take the,
the last possible flight out to go to the
Gig and the first possible flight home
to be with our kids and our families.
And so we're getting up
at five in the morning,
like day of the show to take a 7:00
AM flight, probably east coast.
And sometimes we'll call each other
just to make sure the other one woke up,
you know, and is in the car
and heading to the airport.
So I called him to find out if he was
coming and he called me and I saw that he
was calling, but I couldn't
answer the phone. Why?
Because I had to pee so badly in
the co and this never happens.
I Pete at home on the way to the airport.
It's like 12 minutes after I got in the
car, something strange was happening.
I thought I was dying. I was like,
I gotta pee. I go into a seven 11,
which for some reason I guess I'm the
only person in the world and knows that
there's no bathroom in any seven 11
so rude guy said, we don't have it. You
said you can pay in the slushy machine.
We'll make an improvement on
it. So I go around, so I'm not,
I don't know where to go.
Nothing's open.
I walk around the corner the
way I called it a slushie.
It's a slurpee straight that I fucking,
I gave it. You've ruined the pot.
I took a while.
How would use for Randy?
I walk around the corner
and there's nowhere to go.
I crouched down between
two apartment buildings,
like a homeless man and just pee in the
street. Okay. That's, I had no choice.
It was coming out of Sop and
sitting down with it. It was odd.
I didn't have to pull my pants down
way down Ip as squatted. And Pete, uh,
I get up, I run back to the call
our call Randy. I'm like, Hey,
I saw you were calling. I
didn't want you to panic. Worse.
Call my house and wake my family up.
I am up.
I just had to piece so leave that message
on my machine because I was driving to
the airport too.
And for some reason I had a cup of coffee,
I had to fucking pee and I went
between an apartment. Okay.
So that's a weird I fucking Pete.
And I was like, because I was like,
there's nowhere to go. There's nowhere
for me to go to the traffic is so bad.
I got weird. It is weird. And that
was the moment where I was like, yeah,
this is a little too weird
and we kind of don't want to,
it's almost like we're denying the weird.
Why were you at were denying that
nine 11 was an inside job? Why?
Why are you saying I can call it explain
it. I could totally explain it though.
I think it's,
cause I had a cup of coffee and the
ride was like 45 fucking minutes.
I didn't have a cup of coffee and it was,
I was only like 15 minutes into my ride
or 20 minutes in my right. And I had,
I also think I didn't want to like go
into a bathroom and get a key and then
have to wait and whatnot. I was like,
well, maybe I can go and pee at this.
It was very odd that that is probably the
most odd only thing our audience wants
to know. Okay. He couldn't
get inside. She was too tight.
They were friends. I thought it
was like you couldn't fit inside.
So he called you in because you
have a narrow a penis and he like,
we got everything just to say,
oh,
we were talking to twins about their
dicks. Just to kind of show you're on.
What do you guys, what show is
that on? This is, um, this is our,
is that Good Morning America? Our new
series identical every wake up brothers.
Um, uh, I, is there an age though?
Like is it like a 15 or whatever
in puberty where you're like, Yo,
our decks exactly the same. Did Not
do it. You know what our parents did?
It was so never did it because our parents
very smartly put us in separate rooms,
separate rooms, changes, everything.
This is what I would tell
anybody who has twins,
give your kid a separate rooms because
it allows them to understand that.
So they,
they were good with just being naked
around each other in front of with like
other women also. By the
way. Good looking guys. Okay.
They seem like both like dicks but
good looking guys who good and guys who
should be able to get women.
And so now you also need this ruse where
you're both kind of double teaming.
One girl like that to me. Yeah. I just,
I don't understand it but I don't buy it.
I don't get it.
It to me feels like literally step back.
Yeah. Little rabbit. Yeah. Step back.
What you're saying is you guys have never
show each other dogs and then like is
it identical to
really,
ours are different than mine has glasses.
Glass Hole.
Do you guys poop in front of each other?
Yeah,
definitely. On that. No. I'm
imagining every parent of twins did.
They force the era of like
the match and like, you know,
everything's the same matching up. It's
our, again, our parents didn't do that.
Either of your parents are smart.
They were amazing, super evolved and,
and the truth of the matter is, and this
is like super deep, but our mom and you,
this is crazy to even talk about, but
our mom a year before we were born, uh,
delivered a baby that live
for four days and then,
oh so terrible like to go through
that I came to, you know, as you know,
you're holding a baby inside
you right now. Imagine.
And again at a time when
they didn't have technology,
she was pregnant amongst all of
her friends who had had kids.
And then suddenly four days after
she gives birth, no kid. So like the,
the devastation in that area a
year to the day when that loss,
when she lost that girl,
we were born to two healthy babies.
I'm not a firm believer in,
you know,
some other presence that
makes things happen.
I really believe that it's all going
to happen on earth while we're here and
people have to do it between each other.
And you can't just be like,
I was an asshole. But I believe
in Jesus, so everything's cool.
You know what I mean?
Like I can't do that.
But if you were to believe in a higher
power, like that is the time to be like,
okay, I had nothing and was in the
worst place and now I just have to.
So I think that informed the way their
attitude was towards us and they were
very like they cared about
us and then had an eval,
had a lot of like internal gratitude
that it worked out. It wasn't just like,
oh yeah,
those are the twins.
We just through the same fucking
trash bag on both of them.
And that's what a way,
you know what I mean?
It was sort of like we cut it up
in APP and now they're both right.
It was a lot of thought was put into,
hey,
we're the only kids and we want something
like we were like an only child on,
there was a lot of attention
and love and care about still.
And I would argue this is parents today,
like our parents loved us.
I would say more than our friends.
Parents love them. And that's not,
that's not even bragging.
That's just the truth. Sure.
There are definitely
super way more thoughtful,
especially in that era to be like,
let's give these to their own identities.
It's not rhyme. Their names not make them
sit in the same room, not dressing like,
not to all that stuff.
And so,
but they also didn't know what we were
doing 95% of the time since the seventies
and eighties. Yeah. They
were like, where are they?
Like we'd be playing football
on the corner with like
all the neighborhood kids.
No fence, basically like a chance for like
a child molester to swing by, you know,
Reddit or buffer editor.
Buffet just like grabbed the predators.
You never planned to rape and
executed it like you said. No,
but did you ever do something fun like a,
I don't know,
like with an employer or um,
you know,
a test or something like that.
We did switch once in school and
there it is buddy. It was at,
it was not as great as it was like one
of those things that kind of said to
write on paper,
but terrible.
And also that like we should never ever
do comedy cause we kinda got into comedy
and we were like 14 years old so this
kind of told us never do this stuff on
this would never do that on stage.
Like we switched classes cause we're
like we're going to really full.
No one really knew. Our friends
kind of knew but, but it was,
you did it for a gag though. Like April
fool's day and then I was like, Oh shit,
I now have to take a quiz in his class
and I don't know what is going on.
This is stressful. This isn't
fun in any way, shape or form.
It was probably like fun for like four
minutes and then there's another like 50
minutes that has to go below it that
same year I had a home economics teacher
who was terrible.
This is frank.
She was like absolutely horrible to me
about cooking and sewing and all this
other stuff. Stuff that you should
know. Horrible human being on,
on,
on Halloween.
She had like an apes mask on it and she
came in with like an AP racist, racist,
but she can't wait.
She came in with an AMC mask on,
on Halloween and people are dressed
up in costumes and everything.
And so for three quarters of class she
taught the class with the apes mass.
I hated this three quarters of the way
and it got too hot and she took off the
mask. She took off the mask and
I screamed when she took it off.
That's horror. Took you off. And
I was like, oh my God. Yeah. Yeah.
That's a great bit. Good
jokes, good laugh, Harrison
to the US switching classes.
That was a way better bit.
And that to me tells like you everything
we need to know about where our minds
are in how we use this thing that we do.
Although I do think over time what we've
realized is that they're having two
people on stage. Actually,
now that I think about it,
so much funnier than the reaction
I gave me. Imagine that as like a,
like a 15 year old kid, Paul,
in that bit off. Yeah, no,
it's very integrated funding. So, and I
got in trouble and I, we told our, my,
I got in trouble,
like went to the principal and the whole
thing and they called our parents and I
told my, told my dad what I did and
our dad, who was not a great, he,
he was a great businessman. He's no longer
alive. Great Dude, great businessman,
but not great in school. And I said, dad,
this is the bit, and this is what I did.
And he's like, that's funny.
He said to get laughs,
I think you said didn't get laughs.
Laughs I was like dead. It's funny.
Did it kill it, kill it, kill it.
He couldn't be mad in that moment.
I'm like,
I mean if you're a kid pulled off a good
job, like a good joke, you'd be like,
I dunno what I can do. Like, look, we're
in front of these people. I'm gonna,
I'm gonna yell at you. I might
even spanking. But that's good.
We're going out to dinner.
You can get some ice cream for that.
But I mean it was just again,
but that kind of said it,
but I was saying about the
stand up when we're on stage,
we just have to figure out,
and we talked deeply about this
with you just in terms of uh, set,
cause we always call him the
setup master 2000 set of pastor.
He is so economical with his,
I can take your setups and cut them
in half and make it more powerful.
Caught them in half and make a more
directed and make them and we're like
fucking set
up master 2000 do it up man.
It's all set up to all my and,
and what I love in watching your standup
is that the set ups get last as you set
things up,
you're like if it's set up right you
get credit for the constable double,
double last and then you see it executed.
But we were always like well what's,
how do we then, you know, two people
on stage is very different. Like again,
you know, your point of view and
your special comes through so deeply.
Your point of view on the
show comes through deeply.
But like if the two of you are on stage
together you kind of have to like what's
our point of is like when we do our
live podcast, which is a lot of fun.
We haven't done one in a while,
but when we've done live ones,
part of it is that you know the audience
there is so familiar with the show,
which is actually like a cheat
code for setups. Oh yeah.
In other words we bring up a topic and
they're all like I know what the topic is
and then you can just go joke, joke,
joke, joke, joke, joke, joke. Cause it's,
it's all very much set up for you,
which is done.
You've established your
voice on the thing,
but you know a singular
point of view on stage.
This is the way I think about this.
So we have to kind of figure out it.
It's like one layer removed as we do
our standup and then as we play our bits
out,
how do we do it?
Is it just examples and we're both
rallying them off or are we acting out a
scene like we've just realized in our
latest our of standup as we're sort of
turning,
cause he did an hour that we did an hour
for a CSO that see so folded and now
it's going to be on stars,
which is at least I've got
a second home. That's great.
We were discussing like what happens to
all these CSOS and there's so many great
Dominique Cim.
Anwar Diaz had one on
Stan hope has right now,
so ours, so ours had never premiered. So
it's actually to premiere on, Oh my God,
it's going to be on stars. And my first
question was why not black stars? Come on,
play that clip again.
It was too small
or narrow.
Is that the same saying?
But you guys might know
something about this.
Last week we were talking about our,
uh,
at our son's preschool where
we leave him 14 hours a day.
We dropped him off and
uh, we, uh, he liked it.
He locks the locks up, locks up. But they
were telling us, oh, there's a little bit,
it was a kind of a case as of hand,
foot and mouth going on and we
were talking about it. I was like,
I don't remember anybody
ever talking about that. When
we were kids, split mouth,
fluffing mouth, no one ever
said, I remember chicken pox.
We had chicken parks growing up. Well
somebody, I dunno if this even address it,
somebody says, I recently contracted
hand, foot and mouth as an adult.
I have to tell you, it sucks a fat
donkey Dick. You get how he got it.
He gets terribly painful. Blisters on
your hands, feet in your mouth. Go figure.
Walking was a fucking nightmare. Keep your
kids away from that shit. I fly a lot.
My doctor says I probably touched
them baby, just on a plane.
I didn't even know it. Make sure you
wash those pause every time you get
off of gross ass airplane.
I didn't know that if the shower,
but what was that?
Do you remember that thing?
I don't remember that being
a same babies that you know.
So pleasured wait, did your
kids ever get that one? No,
but it was around in school.
I remember it. Someone I'm
like, and then you're like,
we have lice, lice. We, I
never had kids have had it.
There was always like a time when you
went to the nurse and she had like plastic
bags on her hands
through your hair.
Like she's looking at records at a
record store cause hoof and mouth,
the new strokes out.
That's, that's horrible.
And as an adult to deal with like
a kid sickness that feels, I mean,
you get it, you get everything that
they give you. It's three weeks now.
I'm like praising Jesus. You don't
even know how it feels. You're like,
this is what it feels like.
Take a full breath,
uh, because your kids around him because
you're about to have another kid and
eventually that kid will be in prison.
It's whenever your kids get out of
preschool, preschools to the ground,
zero for all this shit is a fucking
petri dish of disease and kindergarten,
I think.
God Damn does it.
I think it does the adult
hoof and mouth disease,
I'm just going to call it a hook.
Adult huff and mouth disease.
That to me is like the fact that this
person contracted that and definitely
probably got it from on a plane.
Everything is tired of all
this motherfucking hoof
and mouth disease on this
motherfucking plane.
Wasn't that Sam Jackson Jackson.
Do you guys talk about your pooping on
this documentary and we do because what
did you find? Did you find that women are
more squeamish obviously about pooping?
Absolutely. Women in
the movie went off. Uh,
I like they have some confidence right
there. We were like, yeah, there's no,
yeah. The truth of the matter is like
it really shows how he wouldn't touch.
You are with your body. If you are
pooping and you have a good poop,
you know it's a body,
a shit and only Abdo and you
wipe and there's nothing there.
It's like walk away literally.
What's up? Mike drops
you ace a solid shit when the all comes
together and nothing gets on the wall.
I will do like I'm a casino pit
boss and I'm done with my shift.
Yes. Not the dealer. Yes, that's right.
And is also want to show you that
there's nothing up their sleeve here. No,
but I mean, yeah, it's a great
feeling, right? Shit out these slaves,
we accomplish something.
Right. So, you know,
we haven't done it for me.
I had hemorrhoids that ruins the
whole pathway too. It's horrible.
It's a bad thing.
But when you do it and you get one in
and you do it right and it feels easy and
it comes up having hemorrhoids is like
trying to stuff like an odder through a
pinball machine. Terrible. Well, I get
them pregnant at the end of my pregnancy.
It's horrible. I don't
have now, thankfully. But
towards the end do offer it all. Should
have had my dad on, you know, he's really,
he's quite famous for his hemorrhoids.
No, it's shit talks. I mean he's,
he did he tell you about his shit's
like, oh, what was it like door opened.
This is what happened. Report. It's just,
it's adequate shit today, Tom. Yeah.
And it's a, it continues. I mean to
this day, I mean, I get phone calls,
I had a great one that was great and
he's like, I tell you a story buddy.
I was just down the hall
and just tell him no,
no paper and stall.
So you know what you gotta do is you've
got to stand up and squeeze the cheeks
and my pain,
my trousers were still down and I had
to waddle over the next stall and there
was barely any paper in there.
And I had a wattle out. I'm like,
are there people in the
bathroom like waddling down?
Why don't we know with pants down, hands
down. And he was like, it was a blaster.
So there was shit all over my
cheeks and holy cow. And it's uh,
I mean this is at all the toe that
is really phenomenal. Super Old.
But this might be him,
I think talking to me about it years ago
and I pulled out my iPhone and he just
started recording.
Yeah,
he might bring it up immediately because
this is how I used to just call him and
calm and just see what was on, what's
going on and then go straight. He starts,
starts conversations with this right away.
Hey Buddy,
how you doing?
They make any announcement or,
oh, sorry. I was just, one's being
recorded. I used to get him like a buddy.
Hey Buddy. I love it.
I love it. I love it.
It's like he entered the
call like to wipe down.
Tell me about wiping.
He needed a wipe down.
I love how well that was.
That was advice where I go when I go.
Sometimes you just keep wiping
your wiping and your wife.
I don't know what to do.
He's like,
you need to wipe down and then he would
say you stand up and let everything fall
into place and sit back down and wipe it.
Maybe constant white.
You definitely don't and
I think your dad was,
what he was alluded to is you don't
want to get poop in your vagina. Now.
Have you guys ever had a bad day and
we talked about this in the movie?
Let me tell you the day,
whoever crushed like the electric car was
crushed by a powerful lobby and it the
lobby saying don't do the Bidet.
Do you guys have the Japanese application
to their fucking best thing in the
world? What happened was street
we going up into your ass.
You can rob Corddry says in the movie I,
I can really dictate what
the temperature of the water,
whether it pulsates or not and I do
blow dry
blow dry. Your asshole is like
that. Just have a blowout. So good.
That is the equivalent of
having your hair blonde. Nasty.
When we take a dump and hotels and then
you're dashing the toilet paper against
her, but it's, it's vulgar
when you're used to washing it.
Friend of ours said like if
you got shit on your arm,
it says in the movie you don't Shit
on your head, little shit on your arm.
Would you grab a piece of paper,
the paper there and just wipe it off and
be like, all right, I'm calling today. No,
you fucking wash it off.
You put soap and water on them
and then wash your ass. Man,
I think Americans have a have an
aversion to it and this would doctor we,
when we did dr drew show, we were like,
what is the deal with this? And he's like,
I think Americans have a psychological,
they think have a day is like how to wash
or don't shower and they just use the
day that somehow getting into
that will mean that you'll just,
that's all you're going to do.
Here's the thing,
maybe the old days that
were around when we grew up,
I always thought that I was like,
that's crazy.
You're just going to like you just
waddle over to that thing that just,
and let it do that. Now with washlet
where you just go press the button.
We rented a house and what happened was
they had one in one of the toilets and
where you like this. So when we
were done, is it a little sexual?
It's a little sexual. That
a little bit. A little bit.
It is in the best way to
Brown. It's, it's pretty great.
It is great man. Yeah. Here's the thing.
You feel like now that we have
them in our house when I travel,
you feel like you're app?
No,
Adam Carolla said it's like trying to use
a paper towel to get peanut butter out
of the carpet. That's what am I
doing? What am I traveled with the um,
the wipes. The White? Yeah, the white
flushable wipes. Flushable wipes. Yeah.
I've done it a few times on the road just,
just to have a little bit of
a sense of that, change it up.
But there is nothing like that.
Have a day. I mean it, it,
our thing is like if nice hotels
would start to just have that Japanese
application, you don't have
to use if you don't want to,
but I think people start to get curious
about it. They'll start to do it three,
four day stay and then there'll be like,
why don't I have this day?
Curious and am I think we're all on a
spectrum here, but I have a day curious.
You guys want to take your
shit before you leave. I might,
I might not take a shower.
I took one already,
but maybe I'll take a little walk gray
one this morning. I took a, I mean,
not gray. Can I, can I just get your ass?
I just do that just on a fresh enough.
I'll just freshen up a little reason
for a set. You're like, I just need to,
I want to up their
preset. I said when I got,
when I flew home yesterday
and when I got here,
it's like 10 minutes later I was like,
I'm just going to take like quick rinse.
It's so great.
Yeah.
And does Tom let you perform
analog him all day every day?
Can you imagine begs for it?
You have to obviously clean out that.
Oh No, I don't love that.
That to me isn't a, it's not,
if it were something I loved, I'd be
like, what can we do? How can we get,
it's happening. But it's not
something that I crave. So I mean,
for people who had somebody crave you
that you definitely have to find someone
who's cool, hands and
knees every day, begging.
She, Christina, um,
mobs meet thinks that I'm ridiculous for
how much I enjoy my bodily functions.
I was, yep. I, by the way,
I am a little bit on his side
because like if you do good, good.
Tell me by the way, a good
sneeze, like not in cold season,
so you're not in the throes of a cold.
It's just clearing the decks. Fields.
One bag goes,
I'm the one who goes down to this end.
I'm the one who goes downstairs and does
everything in the morning for my family
and part of the, I get two, I get two,
three positive things out of it. Okay.
So I let my wife sleep. Wake up in the
morning. We both, I meditate. Okay.
Half to like do like 22
minutes at six in the morning,
I go back to sleep for 20 minutes.
Best deepest sleep Evers right after I
get up and meditate. The next 23 minutes,
six 45 wake up, take breakfast orders,
go downstairs and turn off the alarm,
let get the dog food ready, all that stuff
I put on the record of my choice. Okay.
We have a record player that plays in the,
in the kitchen where
everybody is and I'm like,
well I'm going to put
on what I fucking want.
This is what daddy wants to listen to.
If I want to listen to a founder
listened to Pinkerton Weezer album. Yeah,
there's a song about lesbians on it,
you know all of it.
We're getting into all of it. I'm going
to tribe called quest. If I want this,
I'm going to put it on. It's my record.
So that's what I get to get that.
The other thing I get to do is when I'm
downstairs alone in everyone's upstairs
and the music is playing, I fucking
fart. So I literally let it rip. It is,
it is literally what the Book Trumpet
of the Swan Song was written about.
I am like ripping so hard all over the
house and it's like getting out every
little bubble that was in my stomach and
I'm not around anybody and just cause
it's blasting it. It feels so good. And
then I have coffee and then that's when,
that's what cleans me out to
take the browns to the Superbowl.
Coffee is like,
it's the second gift it gives you is it
literally cleaned your asset does every
day.
We sat us on stage.
Every day is like the last 15 minutes of
like an episode of hoarders. We're like,
get it all out,
get the rabbit [inaudible] Matt Pacsun
is kind of like drinking coffee.
I like drinking coffee so much
that sometimes it'll be mid,
you know, later in late afternoon and
it won't pick you up. No, I'm like,
I'm going to keep going. I'm having
a bad patch shits today. Yeah.
And she'd be like, how much coffee you
had? I'd be like, Nah, like six cups.
Yeah Dude. That's why I'm like,
yeah, I didn't think about it.
We weren't showering at our old house
and he peed and it smelled like,
and it's an entire craft coffee.
Even Drink Water Cause You
pee brown liquid coffee.
You all you have is coffee inside your
bag? I'm sorry. Was that a Sumatran blend?
Well, I didn't look, I've
got a golden shower or brown
show, but she was like, Oh,
you enjoy your body
functions. See it. Look,
somebody wrote sneezing
and coming as I was time,
I was fucking this girl doggy style.
And
that was about to pull out and not Jesus.
He's really start to sneeze.
It felt like time had stopped.
I closed my eyes and everything went quiet
for a second while I sneezed and came
on her ass.
At the moment I remembered that he
feels high after he sneezes. Well,
imagine the feeling you get
from doing both the same time.
What would you call this amaze
experience? Um, I what I call that? Yeah.
I don't know. Call that the, uh,
like the moment in the matrix when you
can bend backwards and the bullet goes up
in your face. Here's the thing
though. Reading his, his message.
I don't want to experience that one.
Yeah. I like sneezing. I like orgasm.
I, you kind of think he's an asshole.
Right? And the phrase is, I don't think,
I don't think it's possible. I have
a phrase for it. Yeah. Ejaculation.
Hey, totally. Think you're right.
Ejaculation is a little
bit sneezing all over.
One was black and I bet he made her
clean it up. Yeah. Yeah. Really?
Can you go get the towel and real
assholes? You go get the towel, man.
I'm going to lay down here. Do you guys
ever burped and farted at the same time?
No, I don't think I've ever burped
it. Uh, I probably have. That's it.
Anything coming out to you?
I'm like,
if there's something inside of you
that's got to get out of you, get it out.
That's what I tell my daughters. It was
just a fart all the time and I'm like,
just say, excuse me. Just say,
excuse me, and that's cool.
I'm like, what about this?
Do you think you can get this
out of you? Oh God. Oh, what dad?
I don't want to say those.
Oh God.
I don't want to say those and get
bowls are long. This is all fucked up.
My Dad, is it really? Those lists,
those nibbles or those nibbles are longer
than a Francis Ford Coppola film. Yeah.
This was a was artistic must see.
Yeah. That's how my dad talks, by the way.
All to breast feed you these big MIPS.
Yep. Watch suck me dry. Yeah,
of course. He's German of course.
Or Nazi chairman. I liked,
I liked, I got to put some
into a rock. The problem is,
and this is what I feel bad for this
guy, he can never wear a tee shirt. Oh,
think about this guy at a teacher
get works in this context.
If he's naked standing over you
asking you to suck his nipples, fine,
but then it's appropriate.
We're all buying it.
I'm not saying that that's something
that you guys got to wear a sweatshirt
every day. I at like in and out
Burger. It's like how much laser?
How much do you have to
torture your nipples to get
those going to ask you that.
Do you think this is nature
and nurture? I think, yeah.
I don't think he knows that. I
think this is my theory. Okay.
I think they were a little
longer than a regular nipple,
but like slightly and he definitely
tied weights to it. He's like,
this is now how people know
me, so I got it. I'm that guy.
He's literally drooping it and he's
drawing and my son doesn't want to wear
pants to school. I'm like, why don't
you ever want to repaint it? He's
like, can people know me as the guy who
wear shorts to school? And I'm like,
that's how people know. If you had
nipples like that, I'd be like,
that's how people know you.
I that is not, I can do it.
That sort of like we were talking about
like if you were really into anal,
you got to find someone that you know,
I don't feel back.
I honestly feel bad for this guy because
that like what if this guy is just like
really into prog rock or are just like,
hey man,
I'm in a skirt.
I'm on a scrabble too.
Like you're never going to
know that about this guy. Okay,
this is literally all about lead with
this and he's going to be like Burton
Chrysler just shirtless
everywhere and they're like, man,
we always see your net gross.
Come on machine.
Come on.
That's such a distinct sound.
Gross. I liked it. He leads though with
that phrase has been said
by more than one Nazi.
That's like a line from Schindler's
list and Hogan's heroes.
I've been cooking in Tampa.
He's giving you those nibs,
which are like a little
more milk in your coffee
cup. I want to breastfeed.
My favorite thing is when I sneezed and
MC squared right to that or is he just
like taking on like he knows there's
a section of society that's into that
oversight. He's and he's in. Yeah. Yeah.
So this might be like the
head of the organization.
We listening to our,
our friends who we just had on a,
I love doing the live podcast too.
So we did a live dumb people town in
Brooklyn at the Bell House so far. Oh,
snap smiles. You love the in
the balustrade saw our friends,
uh, Christina Hutchinson and Corinne
Fisher from guys we fucked. Great podcast.
Very popular but very popular.
And there's this fascinating stuff.
I was learning like Great Shit
when I'm listening to podcasts.
So there is a woman who,
her sexual proclivity or her thing
that she does other people's things.
It's other people's thing is
that she is Claudia coming today?
Oh No, am I retarded? Hey,
you can't say that. Hey, hey,
come on.
You're doing the next thing.
You know you're going to make
fun of a Louisiana folks. Uh,
I say that so, uh, it'd
be so retarded. Okay, so,
hey, come on. So she was,
she was telling me about a person
and who people will call guys.
We'll call her up on the phone,
call her up on the phone and she will
say hello and then ignore them and they
will pay thousands of dollars for
like an hour. It's a cup of tea.
She's like all put the phone on speaker
or I'll put it down and I'll go around
and just do all my housework for the day.
It's for an hour.
The wants to be ignored.
Like that's how he sexually gets off and
these are like executives and whatnot.
I was like, that's great. Actually.
The two that you could do that with
a new baby, a new baby. I would do,
I would fart.
We're talking about lists.
That's easy Gig to Fart on
people or fart on cakes.
Cake Harding is a big
party is a big thing.
I'm just saying like to ignore
someone to like that ignore.
Is that just unbelievable? How do we
get found money? That's fun exercise.
You can make these videos for
sure. Yeah. This is what I can do.
I can have a subscription based following
that is already interesting and of
Benny Hinn is like a Benny Hill episode.
I mean it strikes me as funny that
her walls would be finished. She's
partying but just have an unfinished
wall there. Well that shed far.
It's dot com it's all about you got
to drive all that shit. You know what?
I really liked my girls in Pajama
bottoms farting with a drywall.
I can't do it. I'm curious now at
the ignore thing. It's fascinating.
I believe both does the guy the whole
time and he's like, hello, hello.
I wanted to and just talking and
it's like saying, so anyways,
so I did this today and I did that.
Isn't that cool?
Not Saying was fine and then I went and
did this and then you have to tease with
a little bit and he says hello and
that's it says hello and then ignore.
Yeah. So it's so and so, so
and so, uh, how were you doing?
Uh,
isn't that guys are so painful but also
like a woman would never pay for that.
The other women would never have to deal
with that on a regular basis in front
of strangers.
And if I can do in any of this weird
shed Harvey Weinstein and people and so
create you guys. So great. Do
you know what you're having?
You know you give a boy,
so you have two boys.
So He's,
he's one wanting one and I have two girls
so like I'm trying to like figure it,
which is crazy because it was just us.
So we grew up in a male
dominated the house.
I'm the only child, only child.
So so girl dominated house. Yeah.
A lot of time alone to raise your girl
to be proofed against douchebags razor
mean just a little bit.
Just a little bit of content.
My younger daughter cause because Douche
bags back away from that Douche bags,
it's repellent
my classes end doors and the
supermarket block out people.
Yeah, it gets him out. My older daughter,
he's laughing because he's like,
well that's true and
like I got a good guy,
got a nice guy who who's like I can soften
her but definitely daily Beta like I
got this. That's what I take
the edge round them up first.
When she was, I was like, she gave you
shit and she was like, she wasn't like,
because I would hate going
on dates where it was a,
she was just like the two
pleasant or like you just know,
opinion point of view on
anything and it's a fucked up.
You guys communicate so much.
Are you afraid now that he's like losing
weight and getting good at getting good
looking and now super famous
and like what's going to happen?
He's going to get on the road and like
there are definitely women who come up to
him after the shows and
they're like, let's, let's go.
Let's take this to the bones,
my titties. Let's go rangers.
What do you say to me? I
don't remember. Oh yes.
Think of your family.
I'll take half your shit.
Your shit is a little too threatening.
It's pretty fun. That's her,
but that is what she'll do. Also know
he has a conscience. You'd be like,
we love you.
Yeah.
That's what that quickly fire off a
picture of you and your son all the time.
She was like, we're at home right
now. Loving you fun with your hookers.
Thinking about thinking about
you were thinking about you.
You just had a conversation about how
much I send videos of Ellis being like,
we miss you Daddy.
Father was in his life.
I really don't think it's comedy
sluts, right? Audience members.
Can I say this?
If we want to have sex with
like bearded dudes like, oh,
we'd be on fire but serious
woke white dude from Portland.
Seriously woke white dude from
[inaudible] who owns a tattoo parlor,
but he's like opening up a line of teas.
I get hit on by a woman doing stand up
once every six years by a woman doing
standing.
I don't know,
like from my address show once
every six years and it's Christina,
zero happens is all guys, there
are moments. It's all dude.
It's not only is it all guys eat,
a lot of times there'll be a guy with an
attractive woman who will stay away and
go, it's his birthday. So I agreed to
bring, bring them and I'll be like,
you don't want to meet or anything.
And she's like, absolutely not.
Like they walked away. It's tends to
be more male. Yeah. That's what it is.
Now. There are comics who are
in our position who but there,
here's the thing,
they're putting that energy out there
and the set is actually about how you out
late. So it's like I love
this and all, you know, like,
and they'd get a pro and
they'll get a certain button,
I'll slap a bitch around and
then suddenly people are like,
you can slap me after the show.
And I've seen my friends who are trying
to get laid and you then you start,
it's even direct and indirectly in
the set it's like almost like under,
you know what I mean? It's, there's
a layer of it. You guys are talking.
If you're saying I'm a C, okay.
If you're onstage and you're like,
I'm a single guy, I'm singled out.
So now you've just put it out there.
Then later in the set,
if you tell a story about how you
did something nice like you're like,
I'm a nice guy. I'm not one of
those guys who does this, I did it.
Those two dots exist in your set
and you drew a line between them and
you just need someone to like, yeah,
and then also if that guy farted,
it makes it where he's not trying to,
he's not trying to get laid. In other
words, he doesn't make it too blatant.
That's right. My mission, I
wish I could meet or like, ah,
I wish someone would just like,
if they're like kind of carefree about it.
Then it starts to to you guys were talking
about on your show about just calling
regular people slots,
like an old five year old,
just like literally in a walker.
Let us let us what that concept to me,
I heard it and I laughed about it and
then I saw somebody look at little baby.
I'm like, really? That's what
it's fine. Right? It May,
it's so inappropriate, but it made me
laugh. So hard, joyful experiences.
The fact that you guys could
do it together, the judge
other, I mean it's a bit,
but that's all the bits I are not slots,
anti slut shaming person who
thinks that joke is hysterical.
That's our, oh wait, by the way,
speaking of ball hogs. Okay,
so she just slept for sure.
You guys tweeted a little bit from
the about the Oscars last night,
and I will say this, but like post
Oscar stuff. Here's, here's the,
the headline. Jimmy Kimmel did a
great job. He handled it in a very,
he had a lot of sensitive shit that he
was handling and he was actually really
funny, really funny about it. Kumail was
hilarious. What did he do? He presented,
he presented and then he was in this video
of like sort of like the next wave of
filmmakers and people and
he's even mentioned something
that his wife who wrote
the movie with him, Emily Gordon said
that that she wants to start a wedding.
It was so funny and I want to start a
website of Muslims doing fun things like a
muscle. It's eating ice cream or riding
roller coasters. I laughed hysterically.
She's like,
I see it all the time with you and I
want it the rest of the world to see it.
It came from such a beautiful and real
place and it was hilarious and he was
just really funny and he was really
funny and his whole thing. He's like,
I changed my name to Kumail
Nanjiani in Pakistan.
My name was Chris Pine and this guy's
an actor and I had to change your
imaginary embarrassment.
He was really funny and Tiffany
Haddish and Maya Rudolph, I'm like,
they did a bit. That was so like a bit
that we would like you guys would do that.
They're just interaction with each other
was so specific and funny and it was
literally just between the two of them
and everyone was dying and I was like,
that was,
that was fucking great.
The crazy thing is obviously we're
in the me too moment of all moments.
Koby Bryant goes up there and gets an
Oscar for this short film for like of,
what is it? Love of basketball
or something. Basketballs
made me do whatever.
He wrote a movie and let her
to basketball. Yeah. Lovely.
Or basketball like w and got
applause and people were like,
doesn't he look so great?
Like we're all forgetting that he raped a
woman in Eagle, Colorado, like 15 years,
I guess 15 years is the statue of
limitation there. That's it. That's it.
You fucking raped a in eagle,
Colorado
and he was convicted or what happened? He
wasn't convicted, but like they settled,
they settled and they bought his
wife a $4 million ring to apologize,
which is totally legit.
I remember that bit for the million dollar
ring makes up for it. Right? I mean,
but here's the thing though that's
interesting about that because one of the
things that nobody likes to talk about
during this movement is the, um, uh,
the slots left this severity,
severity and separation of
degrees of crimes people don't do.
So in other words,
there'll be like, you know,
Harvey Weinstein and
then there'll be like,
and then the guy that like leered
at somebody and you're like,
that's not the same thing. No, but
Kevin Spacey is terrible. Right?
But further to that point,
he actually falls in the
category of the bar side. So,
so we're going to just let that slide.
I know it's going to say
anybody want championships?
We didn't dilate dude's lives and Niley
their lives like the Kevin Spacey's
Louise for Jackie deserves it, does
it. But the guys who do deserve it,
let's ruin fucking Kobe
beef sliders colon.
But the truth is the truth of the matter,
because no one does.
The truth of the matter is, you know,
when you're doing something wrong. Yeah.
And I would say in this day and age,
like by the way you,
when you walk through an airport and this
way I feel about like guns and any of
that shit, yet your life is going to
change. You walk through an airport,
you either get to get Tsa precheck or
you take your fucking shoes off when you
walk through.
Why?
Because one person got a one plane and
had a shoe bomb and our life has changed.
You can no longer go to
the gate and get your kit,
get and meet someone at the gate
and come back. That's right.
That's the way life has changed and you
know what? We all fucking accept it,
right? Yeah. You know, if you're
in this scenario now we're like,
you can't use your power to make someone
else feel like if you're in a powerful
position and make a pass at someone and
they make them feel uncomfortable and
then make their life a living
here in a power position,
you make a pass someone they say yes and
then you get married in the match your
life. Good on you, right? There's your
life. That's fine. But if you say,
I want to hang out with you, and the
person who's lower power position says no,
then he got to stop you guys. Dot.
Oh, that's common sense. That's not,
you don't stop.
And if you don't stop and you press the
issue or you treat them poorly or you
make their life a living,
hell no,
you didn't rape anybody but
you made their life terrible.
Like you have to step away and you have
to know that you're going to get shit.
And in this movement right now,
you get shit fair or not.
And this movement right now and
the way things are right now,
you can't get away with that shit. Yeah.
So like you have to understand the,
and I'm not saying like
you think I want to go,
I want to go to the airport and just walk
right through the thing and that's it.
And, but no, we have to all accept that
it's going to take an extra 30 minutes.
And for people who travel like us
all the time, it fucking sucks, man.
But that's what it is. And
you have to accept it. And
that's the way it goes. Yeah.
That's the way they feel about the same
way I feel about guns. I'm like, look,
I can't like ban it.
We can't have them in.
Everybody's got to be cool with that and
this is the issue and that's what it is.
Well, and I'll say this as we
move on in Coby Brian's defense,
they settled and he's really
good at basketball. That's true.
It's kind of insane plan. Woody Allen
too. He's good at basketball. Too Long.
She's not as at basketball, but he's took
a long time for people to even like a,
it's amazing how long it takes
for someone to be like, yeah, no,
I think he is kind of shitty down.
There's no new news because he puts it
in the movie. Go Watch Manhattan again.
It's all him like hitting on a 17
year old Mariel Hemingway girl.
She said it happened while they were
filming the movie and you're like
that really? Okay, you can legal, but
by the way, given I already awkward,
but this is what I would say.
You can do this. Go for it.
This is really what you want to do
when you're in love with this person,
you want to do it, do it. But now,
except the backlash is there will be
a fucking backlash. But there wasn't,
he made like 12 films after he
did that just moved to France
and the other thing. Yeah, with Polanski,
the one that made me so upset with me at
a 10 year old girl over and had her get
completely naked. I have a 10 year old
girl, he fucked, she was 13 but he fought,
he had 10 year olds and took pictures of
them naked. Well fuck the 13 year old,
which in like there's daughter
is 12 right now. There's no,
you would never be like,
you know, it was awhile ago.
Uh, there is no, we had
as a while ago but for,
but everybody in Hollywood that
worked with that guy was like,
they would yell at you for bringing
up yeah. That and it's like,
it was indefinite time and it's like,
now they're like, those are the,
those are the him two
years. Yeah, that's right.
That's what we're starting with our,
with our movie work.
Starting with the Hashtag. Me Too. Me Too.
All right.
We have to get going here in a moment,
but let's give the,
the,
the full rundown of like the podcasts and
the movie and everything up. All right.
So, uh, we have a podcast of
which you are going to do.
It's kind of dumb people town. Yana
yeah, you got to do it. So w town,
you did it and it was really funny.
I highlight the fact that you just out
of nowhere started doing that southern
lawyer did Yana on Ronald to Justin
that yeah, cause we had like a legal,
I don't teach us.
Yes,
injustice.
Unjustice justices have a curve
on that wall right there. Yeah.
Oh, justice brown lock. He said.
So let's go back and listen to his
episode people town. And then we,
if you're a sports fan, then we do
view from the cheap seats every week.
Talk about sports in a way that is,
I would say,
funnier and fresher than what's out there.
So we do that and talk to great people
on there. Uh, the movie poop talk,
it's on Amazon, iTunes, VOD.
It was in theaters for a week and now
it's all iTunes and Amazon video date.
So that's exciting.
I'm excited and I'm heartbroken
that we didn't have you in it.
And I do think that was a function of
how quickly we had to like just try and
pull it off. It was wrong.
It was bad. We'll take the
heat for it and we put you in
the twin document. That's what we're
gunning for it. And then we have this uh,
audio book,
commodity audio books,
Sklarz and stripes with the album
coming out April 5th on audible.
And then our special finally we'll see
the fucking light of day on stars in,
I believe, May. That's a big deal man.
Cause for a special to like the habit
and not be seeing, it's so frustrating.
A three year, two e, two
and a half years down,
the majority of shoot this one Chicago
tag with Lincoln Hall, which was awesome.
Great. Chicago. Such a
great, great town. Great.
Because Chicago has smart people,
but they're also like regularly irregular
people and they don't care. Right.
They don't have the hangups quite.
Yeah. Yeah. Kind of Nice that,
that's a great space.
So that's probably in May and that's
called a hipster ghosts hipster guy.
Awesome. That's awesome. Um, they are the
Sklar brothers. Check out their podcast,
check out poop talk and definitely check
out the new special when it comes out
on stars and Stripes.
Solars network S. Dot.
And audible. Check out the audio
doc on [inaudible] is April 5th.
And then the special Ed. You're almost,
like I said, you're lazy. So Lazy.
It's actually want to work less.
Can we please get into
something that allows us to
recollect? Anything else? Jean,
anything to mention? No. Take it. Set.
Christina p online for live dates for
five dates. Thompson [inaudible] dot com.
Of course, uh, the uh, oh, listen to that
seat bro. There you go. The Los Angeles,
Not Los Angeles shirt is out.
The ball hog shirt is out for
all you ball hog. Same is, uh,
and uh, we also have, of course the,
you know, the whole store is their,
go to Thomson [inaudible] Dot Com Click
on the store and this song was made by
Ben and John. It's the Tracy kiss remix.
Thanks guys for coming over today.
We love you.
Okay.
No Shit Bitch.
It's all cold sitting around.
Matthew's hell,
the top is going to be salty.
Okay.
Oh Bitch.
Oh, she's so fucking
retarded for that. Damn it.